[Music]
this episode is brought to you by
peloton I love peloton peloton is a
cutting-edge indoor cycling bike that
brings live studio classes right to your
home you don't have to worry about
fitting classes into your schedule
making it to the studio or dealing with
some commute to the gym I have a peloton
bike in my master bedroom at home and it
is one of the first things that I do in
the morning I wake up meditate for 20
minutes and then I knock out a short 20
minute ride usually high-intensity
interval training or hit then I take a
shower and I'm in higher gear for the
rest of the day it's beautifully
convenient and has become something that
I actually look forward to and I was
skeptical in the beginning I didn't
think I would dig it and I really do so
you have a lot of options for one if you
like you can ride it live with thousands
of other peloton riders from across the
country on the interactive leaderboard
to keep you motivated I tend to use a
lot of the classes on demand and have
four to six of them that I've bookmarked
and use over and over again there are up
to 14 new classes every day with
thousands of classes on demand and there
are a variety of workouts to choose from
45 minute classes 20 minute burns hip
hop rock and roll low impact or
high-intensity pick the class structure
and style that works for you peloton has
an amazing roster of incredible
instructors in New York City they really
do have great instructors of every
possible personality and style and you
can find one that you love no matter
what you're in the mood for personally I
use Matt Wilbur's a lot but I use a
bunch of them I'm promiscuous and enjoy
classes from a lot of their instructors
with real time metrics you can track
your performance over time and continue
to beat your personal bests
I did not think the gamification would
work for me and they really hit the nail
on the head it does work at least for me
tremendously well to keep me pushing
consistently so discover this cutting
edge indoor cycling bike that brings us
to to experience to your home peloton is
offering listeners of this pod
a limited time offer go to one pallet on
Comm that's spelled o-n-e PE l OT o n
com
enter the code tim podcast on one word
at checkout and get $100 off accessories
with your peloton bike purchase get a
great workout at home anytime you want
go to one peloton calm and use the code
tim podcast to get started this episode
is brought to you by linked-in marketing
solutions the go-to tool for b2b
marketers and advertisers who want to
drive brand awareness generate leads or
build long-term relationships that
result in real business impact could be
all of the above I've had Reid Hoffman
co-founder of LinkedIn on this podcast a
number of times often called the Oracle
of Silicon Valley for many different
reasons and he among other people and
friends of mine have made me more and
more interested in LinkedIn as a
platform as an ecosystem in the last few
years and it's it's very nuanced it's
very subtle but can be used in some very
powerful ways with a community of more
than five hundred and seventy five
million professionals LinkedIn is
gigantic but it can be hyper specific
you have access to a very diverse group
of people all searching for things they
need to grow professionally that is
explicitly the purpose of LinkedIn so
you can build relationships that really
matter that can drive your business
objectives forward that can also have a
high LTV lifetime value LinkedIn has the
marketing tools to help you target your
customers with precision right down to
among other things their job title
company name industry etc this is
important because better targeting
equals a message that your customers
actually care about and it also means
your advertising is more effective and
cost effective
so why spray-and-pray with your
marketing dollars when you can be
surgical it just makes sense to redeem a
free $100 LinkedIn ad credit and launch
your first campaign go to linkedin.com
forward slash TFS that stands for Tim
Ferriss show so that is linkedin.com
forward slash TFS check it out that's
where you can go to get your free $100
ad credit LinkedIn comport slash TFS
terms and conditions apply well hello
boys and girls ladies and germs this is
Tim Ferriss welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss show where does my
job to sit down with world-class
performances you know each episode of
all different types to tease out the
habits routines favorite books and so on
that you can apply and test in your own
life well this time we have a slightly
different format for the podcast as many
of you know I tested a fan supported
model for the podcast earlier in the
year but I ended up reverting back to
ads that's a very long story it's one
worth telling but you can read more
about it at tim dot blog fort slash
podcast experiment that is all to say
one of the bonuses that I offer to
supporters was a live video Q&A with me
and we recorded those QA days the audio
in this podcast episode is the first
round that we did we covered a lot of
ground we ended up covering around 40
questions which is nuts there was a lot
of fun the questions were excellent and
while it was scheduled for one hour we
went a bit longer I answered questions
or late dating depressive episodes which
I've experienced of course major life
transitions networking uncoupling
happiness from achievement what I would
hypothetically ask Richard Fineman at a
dinner and much much more please note
that there are a few small audio
glitches where than the connection was
poor with the Wi-Fi that's one of the
risks of doing these live sessions of
course we've cleaned it up and it should
be just fine it's not too bad I also
want to reiterate how grateful I am to
everyone who contributed to and
supported the podcast as well as to all
of you who listen to this podcast and
take time from your busy and valuable
schedule no doubt to spend a little bit
of time with me I wouldn't be able to do
what I do without all of you so thank
you very much
first foremost thanks to everybody who
is joining in and if you're not joining
in watching this later thanks all the
same for support in the podcast and all
these various other things that I am up
to you are in a small elite group
emphasis on small and elite and maybe
I'll have some updates on that as we
progress through the questions there are
a few that are related to fan supported
and means a lot that you're here and
welcome to the very first live video Q&A
for supporters only and many of you
submitted and uploaded questions so we
will get to a bunch of those and there
are a million and one questions coming
in on the live chat and I will prompt
questions just so I can look through and
make some sense of selecting questions
but let me jump in just to whet my
appetite and limber up a little bit look
at some of the questions that are here
at random time or are you still working
on the self love book I think this is a
reference to the book I alluded to with
Greg McEwan and a book on self-love and
healing which doesn't sound very sexy
but it would really cover a lot of the
experiments and adventures that I've had
on and very much off the beaten path
over the last five or six years I am
working on that book and that book is
gonna be my main priority after I finish
another book that should be announced
very shortly
Stephanie Alzheimer's Plus psychedelics
latest research do you have a current
stack for preventative or would I try on
a family member with Alzheimer's I am
looking very closely at this the Paul
Stamets episode that I did gets into
this towards the end and he talks about
what type of stack he might use for that
or mitigating neurocognitive decline so
I would take a look at that also worth
looking at octa Noack acid other types
of medium chain triglycerides and CTS
for potential application to Alzheimer's
which some people consider to be brain
diabetes all right why don't we jump
into some of the questions that you guys
have submitted and uploaded and I
recognize that up voting is never
perfect and it can be manipulated but
fortunately it's only being manipulated
by a very small group of supporters and
I will jump around I'm not going to do
these in perfect order also because I
grabbed the top 20 or so and put them
into a Google document so let me jump
into some of the more popular ones here
this this is one that I also had some
guest input on the questions from
anonymous if you were 24 years old today
and living in New York City how would
you approach dating what assumptions
rules are important how to become more
successful with girls so this is pretty
gender specific but the recommendations
could apply to both and all genders I'm
going to begin with a piece of advice
that was given to me by my lovely
girlfriend who has actually provided
dating coaching professionally and has
even gone to the extent of having an
earpiece in where she can hear and coach
remotely someone who is on a date live
so she knows what she's talking about
and this advice it is not specific to
males but just to make it simple I'm
gonna answer it from the standpoint of a
male her advice was go to the same
restaurant or coffee shop or bar
probably better bar or restaurant
multiple days in advance
before the date and then make that your
go-to location for the date why would
you do this this is also advice by the
way that I've had in the 4-hour chef
particularly effective if you start off
peak hours so if you do it say on a
Monday Tuesday Wednesday by the time you
get to Friday this staff is going to
know you you could have a preferred
table one insider question is what is
the number for this table
at the at the pass where service staff
will go then pick up or at least I
should say front of the house will go
pick up dishes and deliver them more
often than not each table have a number
so you can figure out what your favorite
number is you could refer to it you know
the appetizers you know the best dishes
you'll get special favors preferential
treatment etc this does a bunch of
things sambar one it removes a lot of
uncertainty and a lot of unknown
variables number two it gives you
confidence very helpful things on on a
first date now how would you approach
dating that is how to implement I
suppose on some level first date if
you're in New York City I have to tell
you if you're looking for girls also
you're in a high a target-rich
environment so you could do a lot worse
I and it depends on what you're
optimizing for so if you're looking for
Sport and Recreation there would be one
approach and I think that if you're
looking for more some of the same
portfolio of tools would apply I mean
frankly bumble tinder etc in New York
City it's not like oh closest date
fourteen miles away it's like oh closest
date fourteen potential date fourteen
feet away this very dense dense
environment I do think that some of the
kind of baseline this is going to sound
strange but like philosophical
underpinnings are worthwhile to read
like the way of the spirit man by David
data don't agree with everything in that
book but I do think that if we're
talking about heteronormative male
seeking eligible female that there is
there's some valuable information to be
found in that book but I make no claims
to be a dating expert how to be more
successful don't be desperate
also there's a there's a there's a
maximum in negotiating he or she who
cares the least wins and I'm not saying
that that should be your golden rule for
dating but if you exude confidence
because you have the confidence that you
will have other options other
opportunities
that in my experience is a huge
advantage over many people you may be
competing against and let's not get
ourselves it is a mating competition so
those are my thoughts on starting over
at five or twenty four living New York
City how would I approach dating those
are a few of the thoughts that I would
have next this is from Larry if you are
comfortable talking about it do you
still get depressive episodes you know
what let me take a step back also
anonymous this is going to probably get
me into hot water but screw it one of my
friends is Neil Strauss as as many of
you know who wrote the game recently
which has been somewhat apologetic for
but nonetheless in that book that for a
male who does not have confidence when
interacting with women which really
means does not have experience
interacting with women or at least
initiating that type of contact a lot of
the exercises are I think very very
useful very very helpful and it's it's a
slippery slope and there's a lot of
manipulative and kind of skeezy stuff in
the pickup world but a lot of it is
pretty supported by a kind of behavioral
psychology and conditioning right so if
you look at a book like don't shoot the
dog which is about about mammalian
training which is mostly applied in this
book to dogs but could be applied to
dolphins and could also be applied
humans you want to be if you feel you
lack confidence and interacting with
women and I do think confidence is
certainly an attractor that you can
condition and train yourself to be more
confident it is not a mental trick in
other words I am asked quite often how
do I build confidence or how can i how
can i this is roomy reading between the
lines think of my way into being more
confident and I don't think you can I
think you can train your way into being
more confident because your inner self
will always know if you're simply going
through mental gymnastics to create an
illusion of yourself as confident the
way you build confident is by doing
things that are just outside of your
comfort zone and
doing so much like you would by going
into the gym and having progressive
resistance increasing the discomfort and
the range of comfort so that your your
sphere of comfortable action expands
okay so that's the footnote to the first
question Larry your question if you're
comfortable talking about it you still
get depressive episodes if yes have you
learned to live with them if yes what
are your top three tips I have not had
very fortunately knock on wood a major
depressive episode in the last five or
six years I tribute this to a lot of
things I'm not a doctor I don't play one
on the Internet it's extremely to
further and is related to this I won't
talk about anything that would imply and
recommending doing something illegal
since these compounds are illegal in
many places and they are not sufficient
in and unto themselves but this is part
of the reason I'm supporting a lot of
science at places like Johns Hopkins
Imperial College London and elsewhere
they're also a lot of tools that I think
can be very valuable Byron Katie the
work I would encourage looking at if you
feel like you are a prisoner to thought
loops that may not be the most
beneficial or helpful that is a set of
exercises and questions you can find for
free online that I would recommend Tony
Robbins controversial figure in a lot of
respects but many of his exercises the
Dickens process included I have found to
be very very powerful defining the
driving values and whether or not you
may have competing values and goals very
important other things that I have
developed as habits which are really
foundational would be exercise it's it's
very easy to try to think your way out
of a funk or some type of depression and
as as tony would say i'll quote him
again you start with state in your
physical state then story the story you
tell yourself and then the strategy but
if you're in a depressed state the story
you have is going to be glass half-full
it's going to be cloudy with a chance of
rain and therefore the strategy
come up with is going to be inferred by
that negative state so first is exercise
and I really do whenever possible trying
to get some type of physical motion in
the morning and right beside me now for
instance is a kettlebell I ordered it on
Amazon and it was shipped Prime and this
morning I wanted to get directly to
doing some writing but did about 30
swings with this kettlebell before hand
very minimal effective to us of exercise
but just enough sort of changed my
hormonal state to activate my my entire
nervous system which changes the lens
through which I look at any problem that
might pop up during the day ii is
certainly diet and third this is not
necessarily an order of importance is
sleep and i highly recommend checking
out a podcast episode with Matt Walker
and Peter attea this is on the drive a
podcast hosted by Peter Chia Matt Walker
also wrote a book called why we sleep
that has been recommended by multiple
podcast guests most recently Amanda
Palmer and there are a few other
questions here that will also have an or
I should say relate to one of the tips
for avoiding depressive episodes or
potentially reversing a tailspin so this
question here is what would you suggest
is from anonymous and relate it to what
we were just talking about what would
you suggest to an individual considering
a major life transition example given
stable successful career to entrepreneur
what were your key considerations and
that applies to the the depressive stuff
in the following capacity I would
recommend fear setting the fear setting
exercise and you can find that on tim
dot blog 4/2 head it was the subject in
part of my ted presentation which at
this point has five million or so or six
million views and fear setting takes
whatever is causing your fear
uncertainty or doubt in your mind which
can often precipitate loops that lead to
it's physiological and psychological
depression and puts them under a
microscope and I sex them which is
incredibly valuable because it's lays
out worst-case scenarios in a very
systematic way so that you can see that
the absolute worst-case scenarios are in
most cases either avoidable reversible
or very temporary okay so the answer to
the what can an individual do if they're
considering a major life transition and
what can you do to avoid or mitigate
depressive episodes in this instance
have the same answer which is do the
fear setting exercise I still do this
exercise all the time I would say at
least once quarter more like once a
month okay next question here I'm gonna
tackles from dean harrington do you have
a process or tool that helps you read so
many books there are a few things there
is a short suppose exercise training
approach that i've used for increasing
reading speed and if you just search Tim
Ferriss and speed reading on google it
should pop right up and there there are
a number of different tools that I
outline they're all free and you can
very easily double or triple your
reading speed but that says nothing
about selection and I do think selection
is key here because it doesn't pay to
read a lot of garbage quickly and so you
have the technical aspect of developing
better motor control when reading but
your question is specifically read so
many books how do I read so many books
number one is finding really good books
it makes it easier to read books if
they're outstanding and I will rely very
much on my podcast guests quite frankly
and look for patterns look for books
that are recommended more than once I
also prefer old to new so I look for
books that have in some respect stood
the test of time and I strongly prefer
books that are at least 5 years old
we could talk about classics an entirely
separate category but books that have
really demonstrated a longevity through
word of mouth and a sustained minimum of
say four stars on Amazon and once I then
download these books so this is one of
the keys I will read an electronic
format because my next move I think of
really absorbing key takeaways and next
actions more than I think about the
volume of reading read in Kindle format
then I will go to the Kindle notes or
notebook URL which which you can access
when you're logged into Amazon I will
then use Evernote to scrape the entire
page of my highlights for that book I
will then go into the Evernote document
and I will do a in this case it's at
least a third pass of this key material
and I'll put three asterisks at the
beginning of key material sometimes I'll
also bold it and what this allows me to
do then when I want to review the key
takeaways of a book which could be
fiction by the way it's not limited to
nonfiction I also take these types of
notes in many fiction books for turns of
phrase that I might want to study
beautiful paragraphs the the structure
of which I want to really look at
repeatedly or leadership lessons in dune
for instance and I'll put these three
asterisks before key parts in this
Evernote document and then that allows
me to then let's just say I'm like huh
dude what were what were the things I
felt were really really important after
looking at it three times go into that
document and do ctrl F to search for
three asterisks and then I can I can
find all sorts of goodies very very
quickly like that and spend five minutes
finding what I want rather than going
through a paperback version even if I've
created an index in the beginning of the
book or searching for content if I
we have the paper back and I've created
an index at the beginning of the book
for my own highlights and if you search
how to take notes like an alpha geek or
something ridiculous that I used as a
headline many years ago you'll see
examples of these indices that I've
created and I will sometimes when
traveling only be able to get a paper
back I will create that type of index
I'll come back and then I'll use
TaskRabbit or something else or have one
of my employees scan the index and the
pages that have highlights in some cases
if I feel it is a particularly valuable
book I will have them that then download
the Kindle version themselves pull the
highlights from the scans that they see
from that text and create a copy and
paste a bowl an editable version of
those highlights for me very long answer
but there you have it
next Jessi in your opinion or experience
do the workouts in the 4-hour body still
apply if on a keto diet instead of the
slow carb diet that was originally a
book so if you are on a ketogenic diet
do Z workouts still apply if you are on
keto that is running on ketones as your
preferred fuel instead of the slow carb
diet which would be a low glycemic but
still predominantly glucose based diet
if we're talking about brain and heart
and so on many of the workouts will
still apply and they can still be used
in other words if you're on an extended
keto diet you're going to have low
insulin levels or lower insulin levels
insulin is a highly anabolic hormone so
if for instance you're following Occam's
protocol and for our body which is
intended to be paired with a higher
calorie loading phase for increasing
muscular mass it will be more difficult
to add muscle on a ketogenic diet than
honest low carb diet there are many
variations of the ketogenic diet that
increase your ability to add muscle mass
the CKD or cyclical ketogenic diet is
one such example
Mauro D Pasquale or D Pasquale I don't
know how he pronounces his name had the
anabolic diet which was in effect what
I'm describing a cyclical ketogenic diet
dan Duchene also had a diet which was
very much this type of physical
ketogenic diet and with the CKD at least
one iteration of it that I used very
very effectively when I was in college a
hundred years ago but nonetheless very
effective was ketogenic diet for five or
six days a week
then a glycogen depletion workout the
morning of let's call it cheat day but
it's sort of glycogen saturation day and
then a window of high carbohydrate
consumption and then it would take say
another day or two to get back into
ketosis and there are certainly tools
you can use to accelerate that I would
not recommend using injectable insulin
which is what some bodybuilders would do
and it can be very very dangerous could
be fatal so do not do that but there are
tools that some people can use
responsibly like alpha lipoic acid and
others to accelerate the descent into
ketosis there are other things that are
non pharmacological that can increase
your descent or I say the speed of your
descent into ketosis like extended
moderate walking drinking a lot of water
sounds silly but it really works and you
can ask Peter Atia and others about that
certainly as far as references for the
ketogenic diet go dominic D'Agostino
knows just about everything there is to
know about ketones and many have written
on the subject including the names I
mentioned earlier mauro di Pasquale or
DiPasquale sorry if i'm mangling your
name the late dan Duchene d uch AI and
yeah but I believe it is and many others
all right
dieter you started out creating one
today what would be the route you
probably take given the tools and text
as a 19 amuse for those who do not
recognize the term in this particular
context refers to and
a primarily automated cash flow
optimized business as described in the
4-hour workweek and the 4-hour workweek
for the most part holds up I did a
revised edition in 2009 and it became
very quickly clear I have thought about
doing
perhaps some updates to that but the
book will always be slower than the
technology so the the technology for
implementing the principles will change
but the principles themselves remain the
same for instance the 4-hour body I
talked about doing market sizing and
testing using various type of niche
publications like magazines that is
adorably antiquated of course at this
point but if you understand the
principles behind the testing you can
now use Facebook advertising and say
Optimizely on your site and Shopify to
accomplish what would have taken months
in the span of several days and that is
an example of adapting the principles to
new tactics that are not contained in
the book I do not have a recommendation
for a type of muse one of the most
common questions I get is what product
should I create what trends should I
capitalize on now and my answer to that
is if you are not willing to at least
attempt to answer that for yourself you
shouldn't do it at all because you will
not be able to improvise and adapt
sufficiently well to run a or to
architect and then run whether hands-on
or by system a business as I described
from the 4-hour workweek if it's
extremely easy for you to identify a
trend and you pick a product that you
think you can then private label or
dropship or fill in the blank in a very
low labor way chances are you going to
have a lot of competition and what that
will mean is you'll be tempted to engage
in a race to the bottom with discounting
and that will violate one of the
principles in the 4-hour workweek when I
talk
different multiples of cogs cost of
goods and creating a margin of safety
with higher pricing ideally premium
pricing which provides you all sorts of
insurance against factors outside of
your control that can can wreak havoc
okay next question from Matt would given
what is known about the benefits of
intermittent fasting do you still stand
by the 30 grams of protein within 30
minutes of waking up recommendation for
our body yes I do I do stand by it and
the reason is might my first criterion
for any type of behavioral change or new
behavior that I might try myself or
recommend is it adherence will I or will
other people actually follow this
protocol to the extent that it needs to
be followed let me give you an example
of low adherence high adherence low
adherence even though I am a fan of the
ketogenic diet it is the type of diet
that has a very binary outcome based on
your degree of compliance so if you
follow a ketogenic diet 80 percent of
the day but eat a hundred grams of
carbohydrates and the other 20% you
could just create a trainwreck of your
blood lipids and body composition it
could be a complete mess whereas you do
get partial credit following this low
carb diet and there is a cheat day built
into the system which acts as a
psychological release valve and the
degree of compliance what's the width
say this low-carb diet is much higher
than something that is all or nothing
whether it's all or nothing
physiologically and this is very
simplified of course but it as would be
the case in a strict ketogenic diet or
if it's ideologically all-or-nothing in
the case of say very strict keto or very
strict veganism the number one is
compliance it's a not effectiveness
number one is will people do it and to
what extent and will they do it to the
extent necessary for it to be number two
effective how effective is it does it
produce the result desired have we
defined the metric that we are going to
measure okay how are we going to know
when we have succeeded that's effective
and then efficient does it allow us to
do what we have aimed to do in a
measurable way in the most time or
resource efficient manner available to
us so it may just be relative to other
things the 30 grams of protein within 30
minutes of waking up is is absolutely
achievable for almost everyone it's very
very easy to do intermittent fasting is
not achievable or not sustainable for
many people and it's very common I do
practice intermittent fasting I do a lot
of fasting and for anyone who has read
tools of Titan's for instance there are
many examples of different formats you
can use for fasting for different
purposes a lot of people I know and I've
corroborated this in discussions with
people who run body composition
measuring facilities with say DEXA scan
and other tools that many people who
attempt intermittent fasting but are
unable to follow it to the letter will
compensate with tons of caffeine with
tons of binging later which it may lead
them to ignore the composition of their
food because they justify it with their
internet fasting and in some cases the
figureheads of intermittent fasting use
a lot of anabolics and one of the
wonderful things about anabolics putting
aside all of the possible side effects
is that you can do all sorts of things
that would lead to muscle wasting
without anabolics and not suffer the
consequences so that is a somewhat
winding and broad ranging answer to your
question but short answer yes
given what is known about the benefits
intermittent fasting do I still stand by
the 30 grams protein within 30 minutes
of waking up yes I do and skeptics might
say 30 grams within 30 minutes that's so
specific it's ridic
les why not 20 grams why not 40 grams
and the answer is compliance 30 within
30 is [ __ ] easier to remember that's
why I use 30 yeah it might be 27 it
might be 22 it might be 43 I'm not
looking for the tail end of diminishing
returns I just know the 30 within 30 is
something people can easily remember and
it's something they can implement very
easily okay so we are 30 minutes in to
this QA I'm gonna hop over to the live
questions and I'm going to answer a few
here and then potentially jump back into
the uploaded questions all right we have
a question from bell podcasts are
getting competitive and crowded will
there be a shift in your strategy what's
new I have never thought of competition
in the world of podcasting and in a way
I've never thought of competition in the
world of books either or really anything
that I've done in the last seven to ten
years and that is a bit of sort of
semantic tightrope let me describe what
I mean I don't think of competition
because I always aim to create a
category of one you can yes choose to
sort of conceptually view yourself as a
competitor in a crowded arena and play
by the same set of rules and measure
your success by the same outcome
measures that people are using or you
can ask yourself how would I create
something that is a category unto itself
something that is entirely different or
how can I ignore competition entirely
what are the assumptions baked into say
podcasting what are the CPM rates what
this is for advertising purposes but
what is the what is the range that has
been for whatever reason accepted as the
boundaries of acceptable
among the top 20 podcasts that fit a
certain profile can that be changed can
I experiment with ultrashort can I
experiment with ultra-long can I have
guests on no one has ever heard of and
make them the most downloaded episodes
that have ever been published on the
podcast the answer is yes I am always
trying to be different and better
different it's very important and then
better is based on criteria that I set
for myself so I think that things may
change in terms of how I approach the
podcast but it's going to be very much
internally dictated and there are a few
things that have informed this quite a
bit you get many of you have heard me
recommended a million times but 1,000
true fans by Kevin Kelly the 22
immutable laws of marketing is a book
that has come up recently actually in
conversation with many of my friends who
are exceptionally exceptionally adept in
their various worlds of business and
specifically the law of category chapter
in the 22 immutable laws of marketing
and Derek Siver's I think his book is
how to get anything you want that's a
great book I've read it dozens of times
has little short chapters effectively
sort of philosophical vignettes with
stories that illustrate also a lot of
shared DNA that he and I have so that is
my answer to that a live question here
in the chat and let's see what else we
got here all right leaf I think it is
leaf Olson how do you network and get
connected to people that you have no
connection to do you simply continue to
provide value until they bring you into
their circle let me answer the second
part first I do not think of adding
value and I certainly never ask how can
I add value that's a huge red flag for
me when someone asks me that because I
know that it is it is they're basically
engaging in foreplay before they get to
the main act of bending the over barrel
and asking me for a huge
so I certainly never asked for that
and the way you network is by playing
the long game is the short answer and
that answer then informs the strategies
and the tactics there is a video of me
there's also a podcast episode on this
called how to build a world class
network in record time and this
particular approach that I outlined in
that and I'm not going to try to give
you the answer right now because you can
find it so easily but if you search
South by Southwest SXSW how to build a
world class network in record time Tim
Ferriss it'll pop right up is really
reflective of the military dictum slow
is smooth and smooth is fast
so if you want to go fast if you want to
do things quickly in certain areas
paradoxically it pays to look at it very
meticulously and to move very
methodically in a slow way and play the
long game
you have a tremendous competitive
advantage when you do this Jeff Bezos is
an Amazon are a perfect example of that
when your time horizon can be pushed out
further than those who view themselves
as your competitors and if you are
trying to network above your weight
class make no mistake you are a
competitor because you are competing for
a finite resource called attention that
these in your mind high value
individuals might have and part of that
strategy is looking for people you could
legitimately develop a friendship with
your relationship with that would last
say at least 10 years and the proof is
in the pudding many of the people I met
and developed friendships with say at
South by Southwest in 2007 the first
time I was there which was a tipping
point for the 4-hour workweek are still
my friends today alright let's jump back
into the questions live chat - shell -
yell I think it is bark who's I'm sure
I'm killing that name you rarely talk
politics
is this a policy of yours what's your
thought process behind this do you have
any tips on addressing controversial
topics elegantly I do avoid politics
absolutely and I would however say that
I I look forward to addressing many
controversial subjects or discussing
many controversial topics if I think
that people who are listening in the
case of the podcast are open to changing
their position or modifying their
perspective if they are looking for
education as opposed to an opponent to
fight because they have a position and
they spend most of their time locked in
confirmation bias looking for any data
any headline any bit of news to support
what they already believe to be true
which I find to be the case in politics
it is just a swamp of monsters that is
not worth waiting through generally
speaking very similar of course to
religion and many hot-button issues I am
open and actually eager to discuss
controversial topics if I think that by
bringing experts say onto the podcast or
extremely thoughtful intelligent people
who have looked at something from
multiple perspectives I can provide
stories and data to people listening
that will allow them to make better
decisions and if they hear a compelling
case for it to change their position but
if everyone coming to the party has
already decided what they believe and
it's just a matter of rolling up their
sleeves and punching one another in the
face then I have very little interest
which which yes is the reason I have
very very few politicians on the show
and if I have someone on the show is who
is very very right-leaning I almost
always compensate or balance that out by
having someone who is very very
left-leaning
if someone asks me a pointed question
about specific issues I'm happy to give
my personal perspective that I don't shy
away from but bringing on politics to
discuss politics is rarely of interest
to me and I actually talked about this
somewhat at length if you do want to
hear a lengthier discussion about how I
think about politics which is probably
naive in many respects but I'm really
focused on information people will use
to make positive changes for themselves
and others so I generally steer clear
but Ezra Klein I believe I'm am I
getting last name wrong
Ezra of Vox and I had a conversation
specifically about this which you can
find on the podcast
Vincent Mis show Misha here we go
with the names more names I can't
pronounce mich AUD if I had to pick one
interview from the many and tools of
Titan's which one would you choose and
why
it's it's impossible for me to choose
one for all seasons because each of
those are so personal for me and it's
separated out into healthy wealthy and
wise so categorically they're really for
different purposes but it's hard to go
wrong with Navarre rava Khan the the
density of insight per sentence is very
difficult to beat right let me jump in
to another question Robbi Wade why don't
you do Tim Ferriss conferences primarily
because I prefer the flexibility of
being able to have a one-to-many
interaction through the podcast
particularly in a recorded format that
can then be shared with millions of
people at a time I have done conferences
before not specifically for or about Tim
Ferriss but rather about content
marketing which were very successful and
in fact one event I did I think was
eight years ago has a Facebook group
that is still active to this day eight
years later it's quite remarkable so
perhaps at some point I'll consider
doing events but
for the purposes of sharing teaching and
expertise and information from those who
are the best of what they do which is
what I try to do in the podcast I find
the podcast to be a better vehicle all
right you know this is a vague question
but I'm gonna take a stab at an anyway
general advice for 23 year old number
one start meditating do it first thing
in the morning ten to twenty minutes and
if in doubt try TM I find to have a high
compliance rate which once again is my
first criterion other things advice for
23 year olds really the advice I would
give myself at 23 and 30 and Beyond
would be optimized for skills and
relationships so when you choose
projects try to ensure that you can win
even if you fail and the person I know
who's developed this thinking the most
in his writing is Scott Adams the
creator of Dilbert and he's written
about career advice related to this so a
few things number one if you choose
projects based on the skills you'll
develop and the relationships you will
build with people who are very good at
what they do those skills and those
relationships will transcend an outlive
the project even if the project fails
which means in my mind over time you
cannot fail if you are very consistent
in using those two criteria and also
this is directly from Scott who by the
way predicted just about everything with
Trump in my podcast interview with him
which is was was eerily prescient
and highly accurate but that's a
complete aside just to get everybody's
panties in a twist in one way or another
had to invoke the T word he talks about
the difference between becoming the best
in the world in one skill so let's just
say for the sake of argument a LeBron
James or a Warren Buffett and combining
two seldom combined skills and Marc
Andreessen has referenced Scott Adams as
it relates to this say a law degree at a
computer science degree or
a vast career of negotiating where you
have experience negotiating at high
levels with public speaking and
fill-in-the-blank
perhaps you went to a code camp like or
lambda school it's much more than a camp
but you have that complimentary skull
that you've laid on top of these other
two in that combination of three is a
Venn diagram puts you in very rarefied
company that allows you to compete and
that allows you to stand out and be what
be different and better to play by your
own rules why because you have not
developed yourself as a
jack-of-all-trades but a jack or a chain
of two or three that are rarely seen in
combination that works synergistically
epic bearcat do you drink a glass of
wine every night I do not actually the
last few months have seen me drinking
very very little and I've probably had I
don't know something like five glasses
of alcoholic beverages in the last few
months made very little alcohol so go
figure
maybe Timmy's growing up I do like
booths don't get me wrong but I found
that the more I meditate the more I have
developed try to develop sensitivities
just and this this could get out into
pretty strange territory quickly but
sensitivities which which really means
just paying attention to nature being in
nature more often listening very
carefully paying attention to my
kinesthetic response to people and
things the more intense and exaggerated
my response to alcohol is meaning rather
than having three drinks and feeling it
the next day I drink two drinks and I
have splitting headache immediately at
the dinner table so the appeal of
alcohol is as has diminished a lot and I
think there's a place for it for me
there is a place for it
the disinhibited social lubricant that
it provides can be very helpful and fun
but it is also for me a dulling agent
and right now I don't want to dull I
want to do
develop sensitivities let's jump back
into the submitted and up voted
questions and for those people who are
still on I will say I know that we're
supposed to only have about 12 minutes
left but I will go over so I'm happy to
go over and try to answer more questions
I can't promise you exactly how long
I'll go over but I won't go longer than
an hour because you guys are o4 awesome
if anybody can catch that reference and
pick that out bonus points give you a
hint it relates to a boxer all right
question from anonymous this is upvoted
everybody talks about the same things
for reaching your goals persistence grit
focus etc what are the things and ugly
things nobody talks about this is a good
question I don't know if my answer will
include ugly things but it might include
things that are less sexy to talk about
all right let me reread the question so
that everybody can really take it in
everybody talks about the same things
for reaching your goals persistence grit
focus cetera what are the things in ugly
things nobody talks about number one I
would say is talking to those who have
approached the skill before to ask them
when you should expect sticking points
and plateaus or dips and performance or
morale and I do this quite a lot and you
can map it out in the 4-hour chef which
is really a book about accelerated
learning I show a map effectively if
it's a diagram and it's very loose of
course that used to be on it might still
be on a whiteboard at Y Combinator in
Mountain View
Y Combinator for people who don't know
also known as YC is kind of the SEAL
Team six Harvard dean's list of startup
incubators I know it's more than an
incubator but it's produced some
incredible alumni and companies like
Dropbox Airbnb reddit etc a highly
highly competitive application process
and highly highly coveted positions
within
that are often lead to quite a bit of
funding for quite a few companies there
they have a white board and part of the
white board shows the common trajectory
of start-up experience and there's a
portion called the trough of sorrow and
this trough of sorrow is very common in
other words you have the idea on the
back of the napkin oh my god we're going
to be the next Steve Jobs you're going
to build a multi-billion dollar company
you happen to put together a deck maybe
even a version one prototype that gets
people really excited you're built on
top of AWS and a bunch of other stuff oh
my god we're the cat's meow we just
raised ten million dollars we are the
kings or Queens of the world and then
surprise now the next few months you
actually have to build this [ __ ]
thing and go out and recruit users and
customers and you can run into a lot of
roots prizes that aren't as full of
sugar highs as perhaps the preceding
handful of weeks and there's that trough
of sorrow that people can enter into and
stay in for quite a long period of time
and here's the the great aspect of what
sounds like a very depressing story this
is predictable this is predictable what
does that mean if you know that you're
gonna run into one lane availability in
other words like the highway is going to
be broken down into one lane 20 miles
from now it's not gonna have the
psychological impact on you that it
would if you're driving along on a tight
schedule and you hit traffic and ahead
of you let's say a half mile away is is
the construction that's breaking down
the highway to one lane your
psychological response if you anticipate
it is going to be much more measured it
will be much calmer you may even have
had a chance subconsciously or
consciously to prepare yourself so that
you view it as part of the process as
opposed to a gigantic problem that is
inflicting misery upon you and you
become less of a victim this is true for
physical training certainly many types
of physical
coach summer Somm er and these secrets
of gymnastics strength training episode
that I did talks about this at length
because your muscular adaptation will
outpace the development of the
connective tissue necessary for a lot of
the gymnastics techniques or positions
postures movements etc you have to be
aware of that so number one is
identifying in advance when you're going
to experience the trough of sorrow and
there may be multiple points in language
acquisition this is what I did in the
4-hour chef
I took a nearly identical graph to Y
Combinator startup graph and put it on
the same page or the same two-page
spread to show that in language learning
there are also predictable plateaus
predictable dips say when you go from
very basic set phrases and you know I
ate the apple I eat the Apple to more
complicated grammatical constructions
like subjunctive
you know if but I had a million dollars
I would this you know if I had been done
these types of hypothetical cases can
get very tricky in different languages
when you learn those and begin to
attempt them you will feel that your
baseline performance because now you
have you have more input kind of gumming
up your software has dropped for a
period of time and what that can then
inform is of a hundred people you being
one of the ten who actually continues
because you know there's a light at the
end of the tunnel this is something that
is supposed to happen that always
happens okay so that that is the first
thing I would say about reaching your
goals is that it is not a straight line
it is not a hockey stick from the bottom
left to the top right it rarely is
perhaps there are some exceptions but it
rarely rarely is that would be number
one the second thing I would say is
there a few things you want to figure
out in advance I'm pretty sure this
corresponds to Chinese proverb of some
type or another or maybe a
country-western song you want to know
the rules of the game if you're say
engaging in a project or a competition
particularly if there are you know
counterparties if there are pone
if they're teammates what are the rules
of the game what if we agreed to have we
agreed to rules of the game if not it
makes sense to explicitly define what
those are what are the stakes so what is
the potential upside potential downside
what am I stand to lose in a worst-case
scenario in a realistic a scenario what
I stand to gain in the best-case
etcetera doing this type of calculus
understanding what the stakes are and
then last this is the one that gets
neglected what is quitting time can I
decide in advance what the checkboxes
should be for when I walk and if you
don't do that in advance in pursuing
goals it is very easy to end up
persisting and persisting towards a goal
that is no longer worth focusing on just
trying to decide in advance at what
point do the downsides to the costs end
up outweighing the potential benefit of
this outcome
what is quitting time what qualifies is
quitting time and you know the fastest
way to take something off your to-do
list is to not do it at all and I'm
blanking on the programmer who said it
but the fastest code is no code similar
philosophy that which should not be done
at all should not be done well it should
not be done okay
those are a few thoughts on reaching
your goals and let me go to some
additional questions here Richard
Fantozzi how about an update on how the
add free podcast is working out from a
sustainability standpoint what trends
you are seeing from the initial
announcement okay so it's been
fascinating and the overwhelming
response has been I can't believe this
still but it's it's it's hard for me to
refute the data if we want to take
literally hundreds of comments as data
my listeners rely on me to a very large
extent for finding new products and
services and they know that I vet and
highly filter the products and services
that make it through the gauntlet of
reviewing and testing to become sponsors
and they like the ads
so the the number of the number of
supporters has been surprisingly low and
the number of people who have expressed
regret that the ads have disappeared has
been very surprisingly high
it also requires quite a bit of labor
for the fan supported aspect of this not
referring to this type of QA I enjoy
doing this type of QA and this type of
audio for instance could be used for the
podcast as promised no sooner than a
month after we have done this together
but we shall see we shall save up but as
it stands right now the the majority of
feedback has been we prefer ad-supported
which which is really surprising to me
but sometimes reality doesn't conform to
what you expect and you continue to
adjust so I will I will be looking very
closely at numbers and feedback over the
next few weeks all right Riley Riley
Spiller zone of genius and to mention
one more time guys I know we're coming
up on the hour mark I said I would do
this for an hour I am gonna go longer so
I'll probably go for at least another 15
minutes to try to answer more of your
questions and I will go back to the live
questions to try to answer some of those
Riley Spiller the zone of genius in
quotation works you touched on this in
your recent Waitzkin interview that's
referring to Josh Waitzkin one of my
favorite people in the world seems
crucial to know what kind of learner you
are how does one determine this so Josh
and I have perhaps a slightly different
opinion or view of learning style I
think that it is helpful to know how
best you absorb material that is worth
absorbing whether that's through say
audio format like audiobook text video
or otherwise but that it is very
beneficial to train yourself to be more
fish
an effective at vetting consuming
highlighting and reviewing written
material because you have just a huge
competitive advantage if you're able to
do that and I already answered how I do
that with books in Kindle format earlier
in this Q&A so I'm not going to do that
again now but determining what kind of
learner you are is something I have not
focused on all that much myself I am
highly visual and despite the fact that
I live in a world of audio with the
podcast which has just recently passed
400 million downloads I expected it to
take longer which is a really incredible
milestone so it's about probably close
to or maybe exceeding a billion hours of
listen to content which is completely
bonkers
I have highly visual and so I have a
bias towards visual information but
there are some folks also that's Molly
shaking our collar in the background
which is bimodal in other words people
who will for instance to take an audio
book put it on one and a half or two X
and assuming that it has whisper sync or
ins in some sense it's the same as the
text they will read along as they are
listening to increase their retention I
find it easier to really dramatically
increase your reading speed say 3 to 5 X
which you can do as I mentioned earlier
just by searching speed reading and my
name and you'll find all sorts of free
tutorials no email capture no nothing
you can find it on the blog Tim DUP log
for free then you can do multiple passes
of chapters that you determine have
information you would like to retain I
find multiple passes rather than more
careful reading to be a real key
approach if you're focusing on retention
I tend to not worry about retention
focus more on effective highlighting and
winnowing down the material to smaller
and smaller subsections using those
three asterisks that I mentioned earlier
in tsukune Diana horn can you share
note-taking format her tips when reading
books with an eye to retaining and
accessing key takeaways later on I think
I've mentioned this most but I will
refer again to the how to take notes
like an alpha geek I believe the
ridiculous headline was that I used and
that shows you actual screenshots of my
note-taking and describes some of how I
approached this Jordan how do you get
away from a goal oriented mindset where
happiness becomes dependent on
achievement part of it for me at least
is I think these are two separate things
in other words implied in the question
and this this this I think is a skill
unto itself that is worth paying
attention to when you are looking at a
statement or a question can you identify
the assumptions that are built into that
statement or question and that is very
helpful for refining your own thinking
it's also very helpful for not replying
to questions that paint you into a
corner all right so the implied in the
question and that's Molly drinking water
in the background you're welcome
audio Vera Tay how do you get away from
a goal-oriented mindset where happiness
becomes dependent on achievement so
implied in the question is that if you
don't get away from a goal-oriented
mindset you will be trapped in a mindset
where happiness is dependent on
achievement I don't think that's the
case I think you can have both n not
either/or so you can have a
goal-oriented mindset plus an
appreciation oriented practice you can
still achieve goals and have systems for
achieving goals and simultaneously have
practices for cultivating appreciation
yes goals and appreciation can
cohabitate they can survive side by side
and I think one of the most effective
it might be overstating it to say
approaches that I've taken or absorbed
for other people for uncoupling
happiness from being dependent on
achievement is realizing that if you are
not happy with what you have or if you
cannot be happy with what you have
nothing you ever get will make you happy
and this is evidenced very clearly in
observing hundreds of people I have met
over the years who have tens of millions
of dollars hundreds of millions of
dollars billions of dollars in some
cases who simply experience now more
magnified versions of their previous
neuroses and concerns so if if we assume
and this will not be true for everyone
but if we assume that achievement is a
focus because people want to succeed and
that success is often measured in
dollars or money that money like alcohol
and power tend to make you more of what
you already are okay so money alcohol
and power all tend to exaggerate
characteristics you have all tend to
exaggerate strengths and weaknesses that
you have if you're a moderate [ __ ]
at a hundred grand a year and then
you're making a million dollars a year
you will probably be a major [ __ ]
if you are moderately generous you might
be majorly generous once you have more
but these tend to be amplifiers so it's
it's helpful also too this is going to
sound strange but read about miserable
rich people and conversely spend time
with people who have very little who
have have found routines and to build
community and engage in community in
such a way that they seem to have quite
a high baseline
of quality of life and Happiness
contentedness may be a better word
this is very common I think in places
like Costa Rica many places in Central
South America and Latin American general
so I try to spend time in those
environments observing that combined
with gratitude practices realizing that
if you cannot be happy you cannot
appreciate what you have now nothing you
get will change that default state of
mind
hopefully that's happy John Parker if
you ever considered having Jordan
Peterson on the podcast what are your
thoughts on this carnivore diet I'll
save my thoughts I miss carnivore diet
but I will say that I have considered
having Jordan on the podcast we have
many mutual friends and I think you'd be
fascinating so that is certainly
something that perhaps at some point
I'll chat with him about Stacey Phillips
if you could go back and add one
question to your list of questions that
you asked since writing tools of Titans
of tribe mentors what would it be and
why
it would be what are your commandments
what are your rules for saying yes or no
to things and what language do you use
when you say no I think that would be
the question and I may have a lot more
on that soon let's go back to live
questions all right Ryan comes an
interview with Chaco willing the
infamous and magnificent Jocko
you said you initially wanted complete
freedom but realized that was too
stressful and really wanted positive
constraints instead could you elaborate
yes the paradox of choice is written
about by Barry Schwartz and others is a
real issue and there are many things of
which you would hope to be ignorant or
to at least have on autopilot
this is for example why I will batch
order a lot of the daily necessities
toilet paper paper towels if I know I'm
going to need more dog food I don't need
to order one bag at a time I can order
several bags assuming they don't expire
and the same holds true with different
types of tea and so on and so forth
so really one of the guiding questions
that I have is where can I make sickled
single decisions that eliminate a
hundred decisions or a thousand
decisions one example would be
effectively retiring from startup
investing in 2015 or 2016 Minh this
requires an awareness of where you can
apply moderation in your life and where
you cannot for instance for some people
if they drink one glass of wine they're
gonna drink four I happen to generally
fall on that camp so if I don't want to
drink wine rather than rely on this
illusion of self-control that I have and
this complete illusion of moderation
that I can apply I will go no booze I'm
not drinking alcohol for a period of
time and that makes life much easier
ditto with the retirement and very
public announcement related to startup
investing these are constraints and what
you find is that you can apply at least
in my case this is true creativity much
more effectively when you have
constraints if you can do anything the
decision tree is just too broad there
are too many branches and it's I think
very difficult at least for me to coerce
that into some semblance of order and
you might think that creativity in order
are at odds I would not agree with that
instead if you said all right you are
gonna write for the next ten minutes
even though you're not having way
imitating the writing style of Hemingway
very short declarative sentences etc or
you can write for the next ten minutes
and for those ten minutes you can't use
the word interesting you can't use the
word ABCD and you applied this this
reductive approach it's very effective
for making you highly self-aware of
choices that you currently make
subconsciously slash automatically so
there are many different ways to apply
constraints Steve Jobs wearing the
effectively the same uniform every day
for instance or many days of a given
week would be an example of a constraint
or a
constant that is set so that his
creative decision-making brainpower can
be applied in places where it actually
matters right those are a few thoughts
on that Adam Buchi and referenced your
latest weights can interview with the
miq that's most important question gap
analysis how do you go about trusting
the unconscious or subconscious release
to bring insight you test it simple as
that you try it you try it you try it
give it a fair shot give yourself a week
two weeks I would say minimum and look
at the results and you can assess in
what circumstances and what type of days
over what types of period have I found
to be helpful which questions have been
most effective the most important
question for those people who are
lacking the context is a question that
you might ask yourself right after the
end of a work day before dinner which
you then put in a journal or an Evernote
file which is what Josh Waitzkin does
then you let it go completely for the
rest of the day you don't do it right
before bed at least he doesn't and then
the following morning you wake up first
thing you do pre input is sit down and
journal any answer to that question
stream of consciousness whatever comes
up as an answer that question you write
down and I did learn also after we had
that interaction on stage a workaround
which came from one of his clients and
he said are that the the workaround if
you can't figure out what your most
important question should be is to ask
what is the most important question so
it's it's it's a bit recursive but if
you don't know why your most important
questions should be your question can be
in other words your miq is what should
what what is the most important question
Chris Crocker this is more a comment I
supposed to be cool to have Q&A on a
specific subject you want to talk about
too I suppose
hone in a focus for example investing
and then everyone gathers their
investment question I like that idea
stacy phillips i think Molly is his dog
yes mafia spike Doug do not have my
girlfriend drinking out of a bowl on the
on the bricks by the fireplace although
that could be hot - I don't know haven't
tried it okay Raul bahara I'm very
impatient when I'm doing a task I
meditate regularly however how can I
build patience apart from meditation
thanks first thing that comes to mind is
decrease your caffeine intake
this is incredibly true for me I can
meditate 3 times a day or I can just cut
my caffeine intake in half and the
result is more or less the same so I
would say a decrease the amount of
stimulants you consume if that resonates
with you at all and I would also read
books that talk about becoming the
observer of your own emotional states
and agitation my current favorite book
for that which is very short and very
easy to read is awareness by Anthony de
Mello de space M e ll o awareness by
Anthony de Mello I've read it I would
say at least three times at this point
and I plan on reading it many many more
times with with great frequency it's
it's that good and it doesn't resonate
won't strike a chord with everyone but
for many people if it finds you at the
same time it can be quite incredible and
I read it initially when Peter Mallick
on this podcast who is a wealth manager
an investment manager mentioned in
passing that this book generally gave
him two weeks of peace and I'm
paraphrasing here but put him at ease
and gave him two weeks of peace each
time he read it which was a very curious
and unusual endorsement and I found that
also to be the case I'll let you
determine why that is what mechanism
through which it has that effect but
that is another book I have found to
help me tremendously with patience the
work which is a series of questions
predominant
for questions by Byron Katie would also
fall into that category and her
worksheets are very valuable I would not
hesitate to buy a packet of the various
one pagers and work sheets that she uses
it may be helpful to take a training or
a weekend course with her one of her
trainings just because it can bring up a
lot of resistance and I thought it was
ridiculous when I first encountered it
and I had a lot of pushback internally
and a lot of frustration in patience
towards the exercises themselves later
found them to be exceptionally valuable
and that would be another tool in the
toolkit perhaps all right let's see bear
with me I'll find another question here
how did I meet Jerry Colonna that is a
great question I don't recall exactly
how I met Jerry who was the is the coach
with the spider tattoo is literally the
truth and also the name of the episode
he is a a coach and advisor sort of the
like Buddhist Brooklynite in the wings
available as a consigliere to many CEOs
and Silicon Valley and elsewhere
including investors I want to say that
Jerry was introduced to me by one of my
favorite investors and an incredibly
good investor named Brad Feld I believe
that is true but I could be off what
insights did I take away from my
interview with him this is from Wayne
Basinger I would say that there are
there are many insights and many notes
from that conversation that I've kept
the most important of which is probably
the question that he poses to almost all
of his clients and himself which is how
am i complicit in creating the
conditions I say I don't want and the
wording is very important and I believe
I'm getting it right here you could
listen to that podcast or look at the
show notes for the exact phrasing but
how am i complicit in creating the
conditions that I say I don't want
that is a fantastic question
and that is the type of question if you
really take the time to think about it
in journal on it that could change your
life and it's a question he introduced
me to several years ago when I was in a
very difficult place and I found it
tremendously insightful also painful in
in the sense that you are looking in the
mirror and taking a long hard look at
how you are self sabotaging doing things
that are perhaps destructive or at the
very best slowing you down or preventing
you from fully being who you should be
or showing up as the person you should
be in the world for yourself for your
family for your friends for customers
for employees whatever it might be so to
that question I would say is my main
takeaway from the conversation and I
will jump from that to another question
do you plan on interviewing Karlie Kloss
I've actually already interviewed Carla
cloth so you can find that interview on
Tim got blog forward-slash podcast you
can just search the name KL OSS or on
the YouTube channel so youtube.com
forward slash Tim Ferriss two R's two
S's at Gardo santana santiago that's a
hell of a name i love it how do you
balance growth and learning with mental
rest in order to avoid overwhelm as you
pursue personal growth mental rest is
something i prioritize and today's a
very good example of that i up
reasonably early initially today seven
thirty or so and i went back to sleep i
woke up again at 9:30 and I could tell
that I was not properly rested and in
the past I may have pushed through that
and would very often end up getting some
type of cold or flu as a result and I
stayed in bed and ended up having a
shorter than normal day today prior to
recording a podcast earlier today and
then doing this and that tells you a bit
about my week I also reserved Monday's
to
quickly and to a lesser extent Fridays
for phone calls video etc this type of
interaction but mental rest I view just
like physical rest if you are really
pushing yourself cognitively it's just
like pushing yourself physically in the
weight room or with marathon training
there is a physical limit to what you
can sustain and there are recovery
periods that you need to build into your
life so that you can repair and
regenerate I mean there are physical
limiters meaning say by a
neurotransmitter production and so on
that you can you can absolutely deplete
if you're all go go go and no rest so
how do I do it
number one is listening to my body
whenever possible and really paying
attention to how I feel and realizing
also that I'm just not that important so
guess what if I'm really tired and I
need an extra hour of sleep I'm not the
leader of the free world the the the the
global economy is not going to come to a
halt you know millions of orphans aren't
going to get thrown out of windows if I
get an extra hour of sleep I like to
think that what I put out in the world
is a contribution of some type but at
the end of the day we're all going back
to dust like Marcus Aurelius said and I
take myself too seriously
there there's a lot that I can do when
properly restore it and rejuvenate it so
I try to get the extra hours sleep it's
not going to have a disproportionate
negative impact on my life and certainly
looking back at a year from now five
years from now I'll probably say I wish
I had gotten the extra hour of sleep so
I I try to keep that in perspective as
well Andrew Regan what advice would you
put on a billboard you are the average
of the five people you associate with
most so pay a lot of attention to who
you select to spend time with
alchun I'm heading to Austin in a few
weeks for my bachelor party
any recommendations well depends on the
size of the party I would say you can
always go to dirty sixth which is a
complete mess and just create chaos if
you're looking for a good restaurant one
of many die do a would be high on the
list South Congress there's always fun
you can go to South Congress and hit
restaurants like Perlas or Joanne's fine
foods there are also a lot of
bachelorette parties that happen to find
their way to Austin so who knows maybe
your entire gang will bump into one of
those and then all sorts of trouble can
ensue
have fun in Austin let's see what does
my cooking look like these days I am
currently on writing deadline so I'm not
doing a whole lot of cooking but I still
cook a lot of what is in the 4-hour chef
and the basic techniques if we're
looking at say braising steaming the the
the the portfolio of techniques that I
rely on and the staples that I rely on
very much correspond to what's in the
domestic section of the 4-hour chef very
easy minimal cleanup almost everything
can end up being used well as leftovers
for at least two days that's my answer
Roberto Musa if you could ask Richard
Fineman any question what would it be
what separates a great teacher from a
good teacher is the first question that
comes to mind he was an exceptional
teacher he was very good at describing
complex concepts or phenomena in simple
terms and that is the first question
that I would ask Theron barber you've
helped a few of your guests start their
own podcasts in most cases they've
started them themselves but Peter attea
and Calif us men and Jocko and so on
they would have has succeeded no matter
what in my opinion
but uh fly guess who else does not have
a podcast who you feel would do it well
pretty much anyone who has been on this
podcast and speaks well and asked good
questions without too many verbal tics
should have a podcast and limit it to an
initial season and a commitment of say
ten episodes and as a practice I think
it's true it's it's tremendously
valuable for refining your thinking
improving your ability to ask questions
and listen and removing verbal tics
which removes mental tics they do
correspond Justin Osborne has another
recommendation for Austin in Austin it's
very kind of you to offer the bachelor
party an answer here go to the food hall
it is somewhere around second in
Congress alright David Tua Stacey
Phillips that is the correct answer for
/ awesome if you guys want a good laugh
tremendous boxer perhaps not the best
wheel of fortune competitor of all time
but one hell of a fighter David - a tu a
/ awesome
look it up Robbie Wade what is the truth
that few would agree with you on Shane
is a powerful and effective motivator
that we should make better use of I
think Shane gets a bad name and that in
fact if you look at for instance the
stakes sta kee que es section of setting
up behavioral change in the 4-hour chef
when I talk about and this is this is
true in the 4-hour body as well for
instance if you want to improve your
physical condition your composition you
can take a photograph yourself or have a
friend merciless frantic photographs of
yourself and your tighty whities and
very unflattering light after a bender
and they get those handful of photos and
if you don't achieve a reasonable goal
within a time for him that you both have
agreed upon they get to share those
photos with your friends for instance
might be frowned upon because the
positive psychology folks out there
might say you should use you should use
positive feedback the carrot and not the
stick
and I quite simply disagree I think that
you can use positive incentives yes
absolutely but that someone will work
infinitely harder to prevent losing $100
than they will to make $100 they don't
have this is true in betting circles if
you look at anything like stick STI ckk
calm which can be used for behavioral
change if you look at this bar which is
an app that is somewhat similar you look
at beeminder
these are very good at using social
accountability and other elements to
ensure or help ensure that you do what
it is you say you want to do the
creation of incentives and I think that
that shame is very powerful it doesn't
mean that you have to be an [ __ ]
about it to yourself or other people but
sort of a fear of social ridicule I
think it's a hell of a thing and it
keeps us also behaving and not letting
our less ourselves do awful things in
society
as a sidenote so that might be a truth
or something I take to be as true that
many would disagree with another stacy
are you still fluent in all the
languages you have learned no definitely
not but I do have different ways of
resurrecting those languages if I have
plans to go to such country I went to
Mexico not long ago and so I went
through the process that I outlined in a
blog post that I believe is titled how
to resurrect your high school Spanish or
something along those lines so I do
believe still believe more than ever
that it's possible to become
functionally conversationally fluent in
nearly any language in 8 to 12 weeks if
you make it your full-time job and have
proper systems in place functionally
fluent really means that you have
identified the highest frequency words
and focus on say the first 2000 highest
frequency words and idiomatic
expressions that fill gaps not covered
by those words
and it is entirely possible to do I
won't beat a dead horse and go into it
deeply here but if you want to explore
how I think about language learning the
4-hour chef has a lot on this in the
meta learning section and the first
portion of the book but you can also go
to tim dot blog and under topics find
language learning where there are a
number of articles that i have written
and then a number of articles that
polyglots people who speak five to ten
languages have written that lay out step
by step exactly how they approach and
have taught others to approach learning
multiple languages which you can you can
also do in increasingly shorter periods
of time if you approach them from the
perspective of language families but I
won't get in to the nitty-gritty details
of that because we'll be here all night
all right we are at an hour and a half I
am going to try to take a few more and
then probably call this to a close Raul
do I drink coffee these days I do drink
coffee and I try to limit it not always
successfully too before lunch otherwise
it can interview with sleep even if I
feel very tired and I don't subjectively
believe I'm experiencing the effects of
caffeine and the half-life is pretty
long so before noon all right yeah it's
pretty well looking at some of the
comments here and there are a number of
people who are saying yes I did enjoy
the ads and [ __ ] I'll take it means I
was doing my job with the ads so we
shall see where all this goes all right
let me try to find some more questions
sorry guys there are a lot of comments
so what I'm doing right now is filtering
the questions from the comments what's
on my current reading list I just
finished a book called I believe
trickster makes this world or trickster
made this world which is a book about
trickster mythology by Louis Hyde I have
been revisiting a book called the art of
possibility by Benjamin
and Rosamund Zander za and D er which
was recommended to me by seth godin long
ago i've read that at least twice gone
through my notes more than that but i
haven't my reading list is stack of
about a thousand pages that i have
compiled for research related to the new
book that I am currently working on so
really what I should be saying is I have
a lot on my to write list and fewer and
fewer things on my to read list because
there's a point where you have to stop
reading and start writing current
morning routine there's my current
morning retain current morning routine
somewhat variable right now because I'm
traveling in the middle of book deadline
wake up
meditate for 20 minutes TM there's a
very specific room for this then I will
jump out of that room jump into the pool
do 10 to 15 short laps just as a way to
wake up and get some sun exposure I will
most likely then already have printed
out the night before 10 to 15 pages of
writing to edit to review so I will have
put that together the night before or
received it from contributors of that
before I will then go into a barrel
sauna and I'll have a clipboard and a
towel so that I don't get sweat all over
the paper and I will edit in the sauna
for something like 20 to 25 minutes hop
out take a quick cold shower that's when
I have my first bite to eat at that
point then very likely make poo air tea
with a dash of green tea and sit down
to do some type of writing or get a
status update from my researcher who
will be helping me with this book as
he's helped me with the last two books
in terms of gathering various bits and
pieces that I need or fact-checking
aspects of writing that I've done the
night before so it's a bit of a standing
meeting checkin like a daily status what
has happened since we went to bed what
will happen today
and then assigning marching orders as
needed to that assistant I have a
treadmill desk where I'll very often
then stand and work for the next three
to four hours then I get on a bicycle
and bike about a mile and a half to
lunch where I have the exact same wrap
every day along with cold iced tea and
San Pellegrino
sparkling water and work there continue
to work at the lunch spot outside
because they have Wi-Fi for period of
two or three hours until the bugs become
too much to bear
jump on the bike head back continue to
work for a few hours
dinner out which is a working dinner
come back potentially sauna or cold
baths or dip in the pool bed that is
what the whole daily routine looks like
and it will look as much like Groundhog
Day as humanly possible which I and many
other people like Neil Gaiman have found
important for getting any type of work
projects done Caesar or say Zardi Texas
life compared to Cali it's hard to say
Texas life Austin life much friendlier
it's just a warmer place emotionally to
live than San Francisco and all right
bear with me one sec adviced you're 23
year old you've given advice you're 23
year old self this is from Sarah
Thompson what about advice you're 42
year old self if he were restarting from
zero actually be the same advice and I
might grab the I might grab the the
Billboard answer as well so number one
principles pay attention to your the
average of the five people you associate
with most physically financially
emotionally etc so if you want to
improve in one of those areas to find
people who help average you up and then
on top of that choosing projects based
on skill development and relationship
development with people who are
exceptionally good at what they do
and meditation first thing in the
morning those would be three staples
that I would tell myself at 2324 and all
the way up to current age as reminders
and do not forget to exercise and by
exercise I should I should refine that
and say move move every day get some
physical movement in preferably in the
morning
Allah Rick Rubin with sun exposure
within the first say hour of getting up
that makes a huge difference in my
perceived quality of each day and it's
such a small thing easy to lose sight of
the small things many of which are
actually the big things alright my
friends thank you so much again for
being supporters of the podcast and
everything that I am hoping to do and in
fact doing in the world I will have
updates for you guys on many of those
soon I have some very big announcements
coming so please keep an eye out for
some some big news in the next month or
two and really appreciate all of you
tuning in whether you're catching this
live for right now as many of you are or
if you're watching or listening to this
Q&A after the fact I know you have
finite time in your life at finite
attention and I always try to give back
more value than I consume in attention
so sometimes I succeed sometimes I fail
but please believe that I am always
doing my best and I really appreciate
you guys hey guys this is Tim again just
a few more things before you take off
number
this is five bullet Friday do you want
to get a short email from me and would
you enjoy getting a short email from me
every Friday and that provides a little
morsel of fun for the weekend and five
bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoy it this
episode is brought to you by LinkedIn
marketing solutions the go-to tool for
VP marketers and advertisers who want to
drive brand awareness generate leads or
build long-term relationships that
result in real business impact could be
all of the above I've had Reid Hoffman
co-founder of LinkedIn on this podcast a
number of times often called Oracle of
Silicon Valley for many different
reasons and he among other people and
friends of mine have made me more and
more interested in LinkedIn as a
platform as an ecosystem in the last few
years and it's it's very nuanced it's
very subtle but can be used in some very
powerful ways with a community of more
than five hundred and seventy five
million professionals LinkedIn is
gigantic but it can be hyper specific
you have access to a very diverse group
of people all searching for things they
need to grow professionally that is
explicitly the purpose of LinkedIn so
you can build relationships that really
matter that can drive your business
objectives forward that can also have a
high LTV lifetime value LinkedIn has the
marketing tools to help you target your
customers with precision right down to
among other things their job title
company name industry etc this is
important because better targeting
equals a message that your customers
actually care about
and it also means your advertising is
more effective and cost-effective
so why spray-and-pray with your
marketing dollars when you can be
surgical it just makes sense to redeem a
free $100 LinkedIn ad credit and launch
your first campaign go to linkedin.com
forward slash TFS that stands for Tim
Ferriss show
so that is linkedin.com forward slash
TFS check it out that's where you can go
to get your free $100 ad credit LinkedIn
com forward slash TFS terms and
conditions apply this episode is brought
to you by peloton I love peloton peloton
is a cutting-edge indoor cycling bike
that brings live studio classes right to
your home you don't have to worry about
fitting classes into your schedule
making it to the studio or dealing with
some commute to the gym I have a peloton
bike in my master bedroom at home and it
is one of the first things that I do in
the morning I wake up meditate for 20
minutes and then I knock out a short 20
minute ride usually high-intensity
interval training or hit then I take
shower and I'm in higher gear for the
rest of the day it's beautifully
convenient and has become something that
I actually look forward to and I was
skeptical in the beginning I didn't
think I would dig it and I really do oh
you have a lot of options
for one if you like you can ride it live
with thousands of other college men
riders from across the country on the
interactive leaderboard keep you
motivated I tend to use a lot of the
classes on demand and have four to six
of them that I've bookmarked and use
over and over again there are up to 14
new classes every day with thousands of
classes on demand and there are a
variety of workouts to choose from 45
minute classes 20 minute burns hip hop
rock and roll low impact or
high-intensity pick the class structure
and style their works for you peloton
has an amazing roster of incredible
instructors in your city they really do
have great instructors of every possible
personality and style and you can find
one that you love no matter what you're
in the mood for personally I use Matt
Wolfers a lot but I use a bunch of them
I'm promiscuous and enjoy classes
through a lot of their instructors with
real time metrics you can track your
performance over time and continue to
beat your personal bests I do not think
the gamification would work for me and
they really hit the nail on the head it
does work at least for me tremendously
well to keep me pushing consistent
so discover this cutting-edge indoor
cycling bike that brings us to do
experience to your home peloton is
offering listeners of this podcast a
limited time offer go to one peloton
comm that's spelled ho and e PL o t om
calm enter the code tim podcast all one
word at checkout and get $100 off
accessories with your pellet on bike
purchase get a great workout at home
anytime you want go to one peloton calm
and use the code tim podcast to get
started
you
[Applause]
you